foreign
right wherever his intention wanted to
go
that's where I keep his wrist and I stay
outside of that
and his wrist is light now that's how I
get down
that's your goal so don't come in
because if he doesn't move and this is
very heavy
okay
so yield to that or the wrist is like
okay and your Escape
coming out
is this way
you see
this
so you can't don't here us comes out
this way
and this is keeping it there
light will
that one's heavy
like
okay
I don't think this stopping okay what
I'm doing here is where is your arm
lightest it's lightest at the distal end
okay so I'm going to make
instead of Center connection like we
usually do do you see
I'll I'll make it on the face of your
Center
not deep into yourself okay
you understand got it
it's out it's out on the face of your
Center
so we sound here
[Music]
which is where your arm is light
light
[Music]
and I still have to obey all the rules
so Maya has no fall inside of me
my Center stays
here here
Center wrists heels
[Music]
here move out boom
boom
[Music]
and once I touch I'm in
I'm in the adhesion I'm not moving out
of the way
this hand is on the adhesion line
and it passes it through the elbow there
it is then that becomes the addition
soft boom
foreign
and with those two when he comes around
that that foot before he took that step
rewind
he comes around boom that's gonna be the
resistance that I project back down
that's what makes him fall okay
don't don't
look to keep them there
and then try to use your weight
bringing him around with the two
adhesive Pop there's the projection
he runs into the ground vector
step around this time
step around
boom step around
and then I followed
his descent I didn't I didn't use
bearish with gravity to take him down
so he's not taking a diet here
underneath
because he's following the two adhesions
and when he comes around boom and I go
down following him keeping the adhesion
that's he filled up
here we go
all right it looks like he okay if you
go over here you clear the arm and then
you come in you think but the difference
is that
he stopped moving
you stopped your idiot when you do that
then you get them going again
you want the iPhone Jesus to keep him
going
[Music]
to say yes don't come here clear the arm
and get the elbow
you have the control right here
oh moving
I want you to watch his fine line
slow down
long
moving you see
slow down
boom stop move
[Music]
keep his spine moved
okay